they got a got a offer to play for the
Eagles gave that up
he was an airplane guy he he like worked
an airplane hangar when he was 15 to
make money to buy flight lessons you can
start rolling so very long story short
he ended up buying the [ __ ] company
like 20 years down the road and so he's
he's the largest independent contractor
of cargo planes in the country and he's
so you're not even close his Bill
Goldberg talking about is very
successful great even close we're
talking cars before that and you took a
hike I did I did I had to get I had I
knew if I got the two of you together
I'll ask Bill questions I know the
answer to but I just like to hear how he
talks I'll say I'll say fill you in the
cars bill makes me look like Lance Bass
he sure does Tony there's I've never
seen like this is a compliment I had to
come with me he only had injuries like
it I got I got an injury I was in my
backyard is doing work I flipped I you
know I flicked I flipped over and I
broke all my toes I crushed all my toes
it was really build drag myself belly
crawl into my house and my wife was like
what's wrong I broke off my toe bill is
this for today is this sort of say out
of all the athletes I know after all the
athletes I know wrestlers are the most
[ __ ] up they have them all like
basically like Stokely actually or
emotionally or physically like that's
don't cold in here this time about his
knee is back all this well there's no
question they're just football you need
to go through two-a-days and you'd play
16 games right you do 16 matches and
freaking three weeks you know NFL nose
guard oh yeah I mean it's it's just
imagine playing a game every frickin
four days that's what it is imagine Phi
instead of training imagine fighting
every you know once a week it's just the
accumulation right I mean it's a
controlled it's a controlled situation
so you can take care of yourself and you
can take care of your partner to a
degree but I mean
at the end of the day yes yes [ __ ]
happens and at the end of the day man I
mean you want to go to the top you want
to stay at the top and so you do what
you got to do like it was like playing
football do you get it that your bell
rung and you're running you're walking
on the side market shaking by the time
you get to the sideline turn around and
go back in I want to [ __ ] play and
you don't want to lose your job I mean
it's the blessing and a curse at the
same the protocol is a little different
now like when out a lot I'm sure when
you were playing that I mean Georgia you
want talk about Joe do you know Georgia
football SEC football
hey it's Georgia's mascot
ah that [ __ ] giraffe swore Georgia
Bulldog shirt it's it's this is my
that's for you guys that's football
joyeux Georgia's I mean that they live
and die off that's where you spell dog
da WG yeah I need some dogs but like
when you're playing at Georgia I'm sure
even when I was at CU 2001 like graduate
but we'd get our bell rung or we do
Oklahoma drill and it's like that was in
that game I got my bell rung you know
it's like whatever like you never
thought about it think oh that's what
you do that's how you reference then you
got your bell rung but you didn't know
the ramifications I mean reality is this
um if you don't realize that you're
gonna sustain some type of long-term
image from banging your [ __ ] head
against the wall or someone else's head
yeah repeatedly then your Amarra
you knew then you deserve it like it's
what you but that's a [ __ ] exactly if
you're a fighter and you don't think
that you're gonna get punched drunk
after fighting for 40 years you know
it's just stand up you know getting
punched and kicked and elbow to the head
then you're crazy
yeah but thought so fighters and
athletes aren't creating the new iPhone
you know like that's what they do they
have a place in society and it's not
creating iPhones it's well you can beat
people up Brennan says a lot of times
the juice is worth the squeeze
because I love yeah football is such a
great game it's so exciting and and I
don't know that we want to live but the
real question is as we learn more and
more about what it does to your brain
what is that I wonder
what happens to things like Pop Warner
or just even like middle school football
it's all gonna be changed it's all gonna
be how it's been changed so far and I
was driving over here listened to some
serious station and they mentioned some
hashtag what if there was no football
[ __ ] you exactly live in this world no
question man it is what it is and it
show it but but they put you know if you
respond to it just like me and then
someone would say oh you're stupid I
don't you know what I give 10 [ __ ]
years of my life to experience what I
experienced throughout it my wife might
not like that and my son might not like
it but guess what what I've able to
provide them throughout you know our
lifetime together is directly related to
the things that I did when I was also
also I think that the the sort of what
it takes
including the pain including what you
have to face to do that every day right
so football is not comfortable and to
make it to a higher level requires crazy
dedication on all fronts especially
physical dedication and I really do
think that men who have gone through
something like that men who have had to
come into contact with objective reality
like over I think they're different than
men who haven't that's my experience and
frankly I we have to hide in the closet
these days then well because because you
know in a lot of ways you might be a
threat to things like a hierarchy of
competence there that we are not only I
don't think every man has to go through
I don't want I've always said I don't
want my creative people I don't want the
calm
no have to go through some hardship like
no different but there are men who are
physically equipped for that who want to
do that that's a that's an expression
one expression of masculinity and one I
don't I love to see I like to see other
expressions of masculinity of course but
that is an expression that I love to see
and I think a lot of us love to see and
I I think a lot of times will you get
broken will you get them yes let me give
you let me let me give you an example of
another flipside I know a lot of actors
who come to this town with all the
dreams in the [ __ ] world and by the
time they're 45 they look at themselves
and go it didn't work and they have a
nervous breakdown
and their whole life is pretty
screwed up after that because they
dedicated this whole time to try to do
this it didn't work and now they can't
start over that with least they went for
it I'm not gonna outlaw acting because
there are a lot of examples of people
who are who didn't make it and are worse
for wear from it I do understand that
there is a physical reality hitting that
egg in the shell over and over its
downfalls there's risks if there's to
everything in life whether it's driving
on the frickin 405 here from San Diego
or whether it's running down the field
on a kick you know on AB you know how
old your kid 11
well you does he play football yeah he's
130 when I had my podcast right I picked
up I pulled my rolodex out and I called
all my buddies and 90% of there were
football players I would ask that
question I said man you got a kid last
everyone what are you gonna do you know
not one of them had their [ __ ] kids
playing not yet because they would like
me man I had a coach yelling at me for
2/3 of my life yeah you know since I'm
sick it's like exactly if I can shorten
that period of time for my son condense
it and make it more special during that
period and let prior to that period
happening him be a kid I think I'm a
good dad don't you think using me a
disadvantage I don't know if you want to
be yes or not yes because these kids
let's a grain since they're for exactly
so let's say you start your kid playing
football you don't play in high school
so he's 14 I've been playing since I was
six good luck buddy okay I play I start
when I was in ninth grade yeah but but
times were completely different now back
then there was one Marinovich right now
everybody is a [ __ ] Marinovich yeah
everybody's Debs I freaked
Moran Yvette's remember the kid that was
quarterback for USC whose dad you know
trained him since he was like three
years old I heard the football football
itself is a little bit different than
say a skill sport like baseball because
football it is you can be big and strong
and get away with a lot and and make
some leaps and browns right I mean in
football
now you've depending on the position I
don't think really depends on the
positions on the position but also the
kid asked have skill I get it
for you to just say it's a meathead
sport and like you can just jump into
this ridiculous helmet so skilled so if
your kids just like
normal kid he's trying to jump in the
varsity football if he's a bigger faster
and stronger than well gage has taken
Muay Thai since he was five so I've been
working on his hands as a defensive
lineman ever since he was five years old
yeah okay I've never had he's gone he
played in like one flag football game
for the military down to Pendleton years
ago for four for charity but as far as
organizational football that was it took
him to University of Georgia football
camp
Kirby smart last year 600 kids Deep
South SEC country how many of those kids
do you think had never played football
before Sarah price zero other than him
probably zero okay so you know he there
was two days he'd up man
awesome moves up to the to the older
kids because of his size go to
one-on-ones he's up against some kid
who's 14 years old played football for
four years offensive lineman gets down
in a stance I talk gauged out and
getting a three-point stance two days
before yeah right around the end over
you know swim move yes so he's already
got all the move stuff and can't teach
this right yeah
you can't teach dance I love Goldberg
gonna have some genetic capabie and his
what his mom's a stunt woman who's a
freak yeah me know this did you know she
got more testosterone than 90% of the
dudes I played with you know but the
kids got the package he's a hundred and
thirty pound you know 11-year old like I
say he's been doing muy Thai for you
know six years rather I'm good if you
had to think we'd rather them go down
the football path to the WWE
professional wrestling football really
yeah I mean I love wrestling for what it
gave me for the fan base for you know a
lot of things but I grew up one to play
football I was born in a football helmet
my two brothers are 14 and 16 years
older than me and they played the
University of Minnesota when I was born
you know and I used to go to all their
games and all I ever wanted to do is
play football I was it period end of
story
then where was the transition from
office he played in the pros too and
then I tore my abdomen off my pelvis
right you know the McNabb injury must
have been fun
it's
sucked but you know they tore yeah I
played the whole year with it well
played on the bench the whole year with
it yeah and then got cut and they put me
on the Supplemental Draft list went to
Carolina go back up there and then
capers and I came to the conclusion that
it was pretty much a dead-end street for
me so we went that way but I mean I got
forced out of football and I didn't know
what to do my lawyer called me and said
you might want to get off your ass and
go make some money and you know I had
been rubbing shoulders with these guys
for 15 years whether it was playing
football University of Georgia cuz WCW
was in Atlanta and we go to Atlanta
every weekend to do whatever and I'd see
him all the time and you know they'd
always put it to you man you gotta
wrestle me ain't doing that [ __ ] there
is no way I want to be walking down the
street and have somebody go yeah there's
Goldberg he's a wrestler yeah because I
was a football player yeah to me that
was the ultimate in you know masculine
masculinity cool that's what I wanted to
do I wanted to be the man and I get
between a rock and a hard place and I
wanted to apply I didn't want to be
stupid right so I wanted to apply
everything I'd trained done prior to
something if there was something
applicable I could apply it to if there
was something I could occurr ear I could
apply what I've been working so hard on
then I'm gonna make that transition here
comes the wrestling you know UFC the MMA
was big and that well it was at its
embryonic state what years is 90 95 yeah
really not an option
no it wasn't an option but you know and
I had I was telling Brian I had the
largest MMA gym in the country at that
time right in Atlanta is like 40,000
square feet and Randleman and Coleman
and Fry's dudes are training to my gym
love it my new was my Muay Thai
instructor and I mean it wasn't an
option because they wouldn't have been
down there telling me that they're
making 15 or 20 you know whatever is a
jaray ting but it was not a financial
options by any means and so I just I
knew that MMA was gonna be big okay so
it was that thing where I thought if I
liked it then everybody was gonna like
it
and so I started studying tapes man and
I've been taking Aikido and I've been
taking karate for years prior to help
with football and so I just studied
everything man and I'd watched pride
tapes and I'd watch pancrase tapes and
I'd watch UWF tapes man I bought
thousands of tapes I said you know what
if I'm gonna do this wrestling thing
which I'm kind of embarrassed about I've
got to get some kind of gimmick to make
me to give me the ability to walk by a
mirror and look at it and go you know
what here that's cool yeah and I was the
Mike Tyson wrestling I didn't talk for
the first six months I've studied every
chute move I could find try to take it
and apply it to professional wrestling
to where it wouldn't hurt guys and to
where they'd be willing to do it and and
I figured if I could emulate that as a
6-3 300-pound dude that it can do a back
handspring and freaking kick you in the
head then and not talk and just crush
people but then it might work so that
was it it was that simple when you go in
don't they do they give you a pitch like
no we know you want to be the silent
like badass athlete but we think I
called lancer sailor babyface I met
Vince I picked up the phone and called
called the announcer Jim Ross called Jim
Ross cuz he covered me in Oklahoma
football oh there you go
say he worked for WWE or wbf at the time
so I visited them before I went to WCW
and I kind of took it all in and I
really wasn't ready for it to put it
lightly and then I I called Bischoff
when I got back home and I said listen
I've got the developmental contract here
and it expires an X amount of time if
you want me to come down there I got an
idea and I'm not and I don't want to be
a dick but I'm not gonna be some $500
throw around the ring job or guy I
I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do it
right yeah and I went down to the power
plant with a mentality of you know I'm a
pro football player these guys are gonna
hate me man there I'm they're gonna
think I'm infiltrating so they're gonna
try to run me into the ground so man
they tried to kill me at that power
plant but man I mean don't have going
through two days well the tireless arena
is you ain't gonna hurt me yeah it's not
gonna happen you're not running me into
the ground yeah so while saps over there
yakking and the trash can I'm just
laughing because there's no way he can
do anything to me that it hasn't already
been done before so like Shawne Merriman
was you played for the Chargers right I
brought David to go to merriment to work
with somebody sorry for see ya so Sean
was saying that Marin was saying that
when you know he thought youth wrestling
it's fake whatever it's not that hard he
went down the David WF Dubi Dubi
training it's just that I was like what
no he was like it was a beast man he was
because he thought he could do it and
still live by coal stores like to know
his stuff way he was I got there I'd
have to fully commit to it like I can't
just you know how you got to get you
know you got to get your shins condition
to trained Muay Thai yes same kind of
thing there's a ball shouting shape you
know yeah it's the same kind of deal man
I mean your your lats are gonna die from
hitting the ropes for the first time
because they're capable as their steel
cables wrapped why do you think you are
driven even still and you're now my age
yeah same age yeah we're both 50 why are
you still driven do you think because I
I you know he always last me because I
box or I'll do that but you are you
taking an extra step you got your more
tied gym you got your muscle car I live
I'm gonna be [ __ ] yes raise hell but
that's also his background what I do I
put on it I'm not putting nothing on and
I'm not and I'm I'm the only reason why
I'd be tired of is because I hurt so bad
but kind of the pain I don't know the
pay Europe Europe rive for it yeah you
know a little bit we did
did our scenes in the Goldbergs he had
some real scenes and did a great job
because he was actually hitting levels
and stuffing he knew every line like he
came so prepared and no access yeah well
but all the actors are always like
they're all over the place their lines
I'm pretty good with my lines but but
the one thing I notice is that you had
ever almost always when somebody's new
in an environment who hasn't had a lot
of experience with acting even though
you've had experience you know there's
just a lot nerves in it's very easy to
forget your lines and you didn't do that
once I think it's super effective
let's go through the five biggest actors
in the world right now let's just go
through them real quick
the rocked number one yeah in those top
five or ten as far as big movies yuppity
stuff who's Lucas
he's killing he's in the he's in the new
was that movie not bad Matt's Blade
Runner yeah he's in Blade Runner - I
heard a bunch of critics talking about
him he's like he brought a real human
face that character it's like you know I
really just you look at these guys from
this wrestling match we do well you guys
are but yeah we act we acted our
underwear in front of millions of people
live on television weekly yeah yeah so
when I watched the rockwork back piano
and sing a song you ever see him do that
I mean he plays he sang the song and it
was a it was a you look wonderful
no no cinema Moana is a Disney he's
fanatical sure that's what he does
yeah he's an imitator man he loves him
that's what he loves putting smiles on
people's faces making their emotions
change when we're and I know I don't see
getting to act and I'll say you would
have done it by now John Cena yeah there
you go
but the Brock Lesnar I feel like he has
no desire to know he'll never do that
Boston and I talk about it you know
we're just different you know we're just
different I'm you in Austin remind me of
each other I yeah that's great I
freaking love uncle I love that he's the
best so call me up randomly and just
have this well Howard long conversation
Austin whatever it is driving from Texas
he's he's he's a good dude what you see
is what you get he's a great guy you
know it
some people thrive I don't thrive for
attention
I thrive for I don't know I push women
accomplishment competition yeah Here
Come history well I'd like the mystery
of it like I don't know but see the
difference I like to say Roxanne
entertainer and I'm a competitor
I'd rather compete and have no number on
my back and just just paid me I might be
right there he just [ __ ] killed that
guy I don't know who he is I don't care
it is but man I don't you know I don't
have to know my name I just want him
from this is competitor so it's
different and I mean I did my deal I was
in front of the camera a lot it was
nerve-racking I just I don't want to
listen to why I remember playing
volleyball in time had Brendan see I
didn't give a story harm compared like
him I'm not know you're like disagree
with that no no what are your challenge
though because we were we just playing
this game and you know Brendan's the
only pro athlete there and the beach
volleyball is nobody support unless you
play it but this girl iliza shlesinger
is a great comic she looks at him she's
on our side and she goes man I thought
you'd be you know you're pro athlete I
thought you'd be better
I see Brendan and Brendan at Tony
Jeffries who was I took a bronze medal
in the Olympics in boxing these two
athletes of each other and I saw Brennan
look at Tony goes we have to win they
were diving for all spike in it they're
like [ __ ] situations you know you can
completely put it to the side you know
celebrity softball games you know I'm
playing a nameless goal tournament in
two weeks right
52 others other 52 Hall of Famers right
you think I give a [ __ ] about a man I
break clubs and let people hunt for me
yeah so but I am come at ER what it is
I'm competitive I like to no matter what
I don't want to go out and you know I
did the Bob Hope right on national
television and I play four different
courses man I mean I'd hit him sideways
I've been horrible and I know I'm bad I
don't want to be unrealistic but damn it
I want to at least hit the ball straight
you know
yeah stuff doesn't bother me yeah do you
do you take acting lessons you get with
an acting coach nothing just do it
yeah well all the years it's quite
obvious I don't because I don't do [ __ ]
I'm not in the big movies and all that
stuff but well go Birds I'm if you're on
the golden blaze my brother he's [ __ ]
good man yeah yeah Goldberg can't play
on the Goldbergs or some mother hired
wrong let's go do you know you did a
good job when while you're doing this
this scenes I knew this they they write
you in for more yeah when they watch
that and all the producers were watching
him they were like okay this guy can do
it cuz you never know and he was hitting
all these different levels so what
happens to writers they go this guy can
handle anything I write new episode do
you want to do more acting like dude do
you look at the rock and Batista and
you're like yeah you know I'd love to
man but I don't I'm lazy I don't want to
work for it first of all you become San
Diego and he's never staying here he if
he has to wake up at 3:30 in the morning
that's what he does and he's gonna drive
to LA he's not I drove every day Mac we
did The Longest Yard [ __ ] I drove every
day and came along every day
he's out of his mind you know I mean I
I'm not what is that you just hate LA no
30 acres man you know I got horses dogs
goats my family I got caught cars ice
everywhere dad said you know an hour to
half from here so if I'm done with
working at 7 o'clock
my family's an hour and a half away dude
and they're just hanging out and I could
be with them for sure so if it's all
about me driving and you know having to
wake up early [ __ ] I don't sleep anyway
so let's go ahead and get that Goldberg
chopper though yeah that's what I'm
shooting for
let's sell some of those cars and get
this south some of those cars cuz he's
got some he's got some cars how many
cars 26 26 cars you have a favorite 1970
boss 429 Mustang campaigned in the
Vietnam War one of one automatic boss
for two and I must be in existence how
much that go for I mean I don't know
whether than two million yeah I was
gonna say it's only one of the let's got
800 miles on it sir 250,000 servicemen
saw
it's it's the most that I was assuming
at least what yeah easy so it's a piece
of art I mean there's no question that
car is a PC is what about current cars
yeah you only collect the old ones oh no
I mean you know I've had horses and
Ferraris and all that kind of stuff but
I'm uh I mean these new dodges that I
got to hell cat and I got the demon
coming and you know they're they're real
there's a demon there they're reasonably
priced death machine they're also as
American as flocked there I think Miriam
I think of a hell coming and I've got 69
you know Hemi charger so it's cool
thanks to it and I do a lot of work with
graveyard Carz and we're putting a
Hellcat motor my 99 truck Dodge Ram and
I'm just trying to have fun with it and
Dodge is a great company I mean I'm not
their spokesperson like then I'll throw
them some love you know they they hooked
me up all the time I'm staying in their
high performance area and hey anytime
you can buy a car under a hundred grand
with almost a thousand horsepower
straight from the factory I believe it's
a fastest car in the world
not fast at auction thousand that were
horsepower 940 just I chalked up mm a
little exhaust on a little much but it's
only car the world to pop wheelie and
it's American it's under $100 you think
I'm immature for my age
they make 3,000 of them right you pay
less than a hundred grand the things
made money right when you buy correct
he's the great I go I go built of course
knowing the answer again and the
producers did I go
you work your neck he goes yeah I got a
four way I got a four way I'm like of
course you this way this way this way
this way I work on deck every day let's
see a night thing is with me is if I
don't train at your fee sets in and not
only do I look like I'm 140 pounds but
my I can't function properly because I
it's hard to lift my shoulder if I don't
do my delts because my rotator cuffs
completely shredded you like that I like
that you like too
about 280 when you get down about 265
your skin right now and you feel a
little skinny little vulnerable right
now
feel like your arms a little skinny
don't lie to me you [ __ ] cuz you said
any of you guys I like reading but I
paid about 280 cuz I do feel training
fat how much were you i think about what
most guys suffer from that's how much
did you weigh when you compete against
brock blessing the last time yeah bring
that up chin 72 72 I think I mean you
know what's funny about you guys we get
makes sense that you actually feel
vulnerable when you're not huge because
you put yourself against other huge guys
absolutely right so then so that one
thing and and I were the last time 13
years ago I was 285 when I stepped in
the ring look at him Brock's a frickin
monster monster great guy too great they
need a great guy I love him to death eat
I'd do anything he was so nice to me man
what he shouldn't have wonderful guy
yeah there's no reason for him to be a
dude how much fun is this for you guys
oh oh you didn't fight you shut up
oh my doubt was just cuz I hit it
because when you're 270 instead of 290
you don't have your delts anymore don't
have your traps anymore as as like as a
I mean that's a straight up football
tackle
this is awesome
who is that guy hey do you tame him but
I just I never watch anything that I
don't know chance she's rushed rock
fights in UFC again if he wants to I
think he I think he does I think he does
I think it may be in his plans yeah
although although I think it would the
John Jones was been the fight yeah of
Monaco wrench into it yeah a huge I
don't know he's if it ain't John it
ain't gonna be there's nobody big enough
right geez I'll see the big pay-per-view
draw but who Xena go against nobody
there no nobody is no one for him
that's hot number yeah exactly that's it
yeah yeah exactly
thank you and I only say Connor because
Connors are opened his mouth against all
the WWE guys and he says about Brock I
kind of do WWE match against you know
doing something hard yeah you great he's
such a character and and I got a
question for you being a fighter why I
make these I'd make mention it's people
do all the time there's not there's
there's very few fighters that given the
opportunity would pass up being a pro
wrestler agree I agree 100% I think
every UFC fighter if they could make the
money and get the notoriety that a gold
in a heartbeat yeah I think I would be
the next Macho Man Randy Savage yeah you
yeah I would be what one person would I
be Razor Ramon I would be tannish it
here long Oh acting over-the-top yet
you'd be doing everything there's a
reason why you see everyone like talking
[ __ ] to WB it's that's that's the model
man you know there are guys like Derrick
Lewis I can see moving into that later
eventually because he's got such a
personality absolutely but the the issue
comes you know where you know if you and
I've had this issue doing I've talked
about this with stone cold where you
know the UFC is like a legit five major
sport where WWE it
like you said it's controlled how would
you how would you how would you describe
pro wrestling cuz you can't say it's a
it's one of the five major sports right
no it's sports entertainment it's
correct its predetermined a threat it's
a predetermined sporting event so I
think that they're either some people
get the argument or they blur the line
psyche because and I think it's a little
bit blurred because Brock who is a huge
huge star won the base of all time with
you and stone cold in the rock came over
and made the transition but people
forget Brock has a legit wrestling
background the wrestler before he was a
pro rest
back talked crap about pro wrestling
once I was at the top back at WCW and he
swore he'd never do anything like that
we all have done that everyone does that
because as a football players like a
real fighter he like now but that's
that's easy that's fake but all of them
that would jump at the opportunity no
question question yeah guys like Kurt
Angle who want to call Medellin and Kurt
said that he got he took more punishment
doing professional wrestling and he ever
did as a recipe absolutely yeah
there it's not it's not bearable broke
his neck I'm not even can put then but
then show you have Brock Lesnar made the
transition obviously legit n-c-double-a
wrestler
pro football player like yourself thing
goes WWE huge star goes the UFC UFC
heavyweight champion so legit what
Brockton the short amount of time is
ridiculous and get enough credit beat
Frank Mir it's silly man you know he
beats him yeah well yeah we mean just
but not even that not even that where he
started off at oh no and who he's
fighting you see silly like with the
Heath herrings and all that it's crazy
so you have that but then to the other
side that you have a galaxy and punk who
has no background zero background well
we just we saw the difference but but
that's where the lines get blurred like
the galaxy I'll try and edit you know
like anything these days people got to
be [ __ ] informed before they give it
their opinion about something yeah right
correct well they're going as opinion
kids of social media now also also I
like everybody was a boxing was a boy
everyone's above but everybody was a
boxing genius prior to this
although even now even now I get all the
time all of my freaking barber it was
giving me tips on how Floyd Mayweather
should do and all this stuff yeah it's
hilarious but with that CM Punk stuff
was was the pro wrestling world
embarrassed by it cuz I don't see him
Punk a little I've trained with him at
the great skating stuff like that I was
embarrassed for him he still wants to
fight he still thinks he says you know
fighting you see he's I don't know CM
Punk I guess you don't I don't know
hats off to him for taking the jump and
putting his making the lockout on that
platter and yeah saying here check it
out and I would say yes if he had gotten
into a smaller MMA show but to jump into
the UFC are you gonna turn that you got
the payday here that's like that's like
if WWE or somebody offered me 5 million
bucks to come back and do one match and
I weighed 220 yeah right didn't he lobby
for it himself that's what I thought no
it doesn't matter though does you're
missing the point if someone got let's
say I've zero acting experience that's
this one goes we want you to new Batman
I'm not giving and here's 16 million
dollars and I go oh let's back the track
up let me start you you look at the plus
and minuses and you way way a man it's a
huge opportunity at the end of the day
if it means more to you than to have
just to have done it and going out and
getting your ass waxed and already short
period of time you can use can you
overlook that and I mean I don't know I
yeah fighting I've always found it a
little bit different because it's you
know there's a reason for example they
will not sanction certain fighters
without sewing Bob no question they just
say oh no there's 49 I know been very
rare and most the physicians were like
they had a whole article about a lot of
the physicians were like you know this
is this is very iffy and stuff like that
however Connors been laced in his close
up forever yeah in such a legit fighter
in a different champions yes yes yeah
you're talking about him be free I've
been hearing about him way before you
know anything else the only guy you lost
it was Neil who had no football
experience and was all-pro tackle for
the
the Patriots mmm talk about a freak both
yeah whereas I just always thought that
CM Punk thing was just almost a dress
yeah yeah cash grab
CCM person oh here's the thing CM Punk
fighting in the UFC with zero background
is less dangerous than Connor fighting
Floyd Mayweather Connor fighting for
Mayweather is much more dangerous than
CM Punk fighting mickey gall in the UFC
yeah because he starts we can just run
shot choked out yeah yeah that's exactly
right
I just that for me it's reading for me
it was yeah I was like it was like for
me it was like ooh boy if you're gonna
take the UFC and turn it into a
spectacle where it's been such a pure
form of competition for as a fan that
was where I went mmm
I don't think he belongs today I might
have me a prize there for a little while
yeah let it ride you had pride was guys
are killers pride big killers in that in
that ring
I remember going to pride the first time
when i commentated with Mauro and boss
fry and lebanner and then SAP and
llegará
she's when SAP frickin Palin around
again
and then his neck up for life she hears
kirtan oh man and I told this story
before but we're going back in the
locker but I'm walking him a Bob Bob
walks by my gear and I walk by in the
Gerrits reaches that grasped me and he
looks yes your friend he tried to kill
me I'm like isn't that kind of the point
in that what we're doing here but the
ref jumps in before he does remember
beating herring for the first time or
than Josh Barnett and I had breakfast he
was the baby-faced assassin yeah man and
cro cop invited me to Croatia what was
what was Japan what would be behind the
scenes that prize like like is that was
like Yakuza that was all behind the
scenes out ash everywhere and you what
no I can't remember the name of the
place but we were out till 4:00 in the
morning these guys are fighting that day
while Shinjuku than that yeah yeah
Shinjuku that red well the fighters are
saying that yeah yeah I was with them
I got in a fight with fry to try to get
him to go home
Wow he and Coleman yeah those guys are
nuts
they're wild back then but that was the
nature of the business was the vision
Wild West to be those who are these
nomads like you are these outlaws and
like it's just dip now because that's
just yeah yeah like it's what you did it
was such an honor to be friends with all
those guys hands oh and all of them do
some of the greatest people on earth
they're just wonderful guys and they
remind me of my football playing team
yeah Wanderlei Silva when he was like
Wanderlei Jessica Raab Josh Barnett and
Sakuraba Tom out two guys who do
professional wrestling yeah Josh Barnett
it's big and wrestling you not heating
wrestling's bigger than fighting in
Japan so he and Josh Bryant's
hugeinjapan does this bro wrestling why
do you think III knew I quote unquote
made it when I went to Japan and wrestle
realize I wanted to follow and Hogan's
footsteps because he had done that and
when I when I was studying the wrestling
business I'd found these tapes of him
going to Japan and it was a big deal
back why is it why is it so big over why
they love it over there I don't know man
this comic book thing it's coke lights
animation it's really it's really wicked
man and fighting over it and wrestling
and fight the weather is completely
different because they don't make it you
could hear a pin drop
yes the whole match could hear a pin
drop yeah yeah like what's going on
yeah no false finish I ain't false
finish and then people won't care yeah
I'm sure you being around all these guys
and being around pride and UFC and lead
XE and Strikeforce and all these
affliction all that I'm sure someone's
asked you to fight you know tonight I I
was seriously considering it with glory
right when I was training when this was
I wasn't even considering going back and
into wrestling anymore and I was really
getting into sparring how long does is
two years ago okay so recently uh yeah
but I mean I'm 50 right and so I wanted
to I wanted to do like an exhibition at
glory and then they offered me like the
most ridiculous a month
those two oranges okay I'm used to one
thing and and they're used to something
else I mean they're offered me X and it
was more than they'd offered any other
fighters like what is this I'm like man
you need to offer your fighters and a
lot more yeah yeah maybe down the road
they're big enough to do something like
that but they've got their niche right
now and it wasn't the time or the place
but I wanted to do like an exhibition
with Marilyn or something that'd be sick
man I'd watch that American train yeah
he's trained for a train he was a
trained dancer yeah take a fight no
Brazil
I hear he's trying to he's thinking I'm
gonna fight now yeah I've heard that too
huh he was working with Bellator I've
seen him all around Sean's a great guy
he's that obviously a monster but I just
don't ya know yeah well yeah fighting is
uh I don't know it's who L of the dough
W right now the current roster do you
think could make the transition by views
it is tough to for me to pass judgment
on anybody in the current roster because
I wasn't there long enough to really
know the guys I mean they're completes a
completely different group of guys it's
like who do you know in the NFL now [ __ ]
I know GM's and coaches the older guys
yeah just old guys you know I mean I
just I I mean obviously the usual
suspects ankle would have kicked some
ass Shelton Benjamin would have had one
hell of an opportunity Robert said he
thought about it he'd never could have
done it no way synthetic so because I
just don't think I don't know I don't
know if he had any background in it
whatsoever
I think I was probably torn up
physically to a point where it wasn't
realistic for me to even consider it
because when I got done football even if
the money was huge man I tore my [ __ ]
right off of my pelvis I couldn't walk
over like eight months yeah athletic
pube out you played football out long in
the rock the rock kind of set the bench
in Miami but I said I mean I then you
played pro for how many years four years
but a
Locke went to Canada had a cup of coffee
came back down somewhat broken had a
half a cup of coffee
I want to buff learn how to cappuccino
but you know I mean I I just I don't
know I don't you look at guys who are on
the football field and it's possible in
you know the right training scenario for
any one of them to compete you know it's
all here in here in here or it is like
really you can you know you see guy
who's fit like Bureau magic JJ Watt
fought in the UFC I'm like yeah he's a
freak but it's just a different animal
fight how would he get it from if Brock
Lesnar's across the cage he's just as
big just athletic yeah and then he's a
better wrestler how's he gonna deal with
that brush yeah we don't know well you
do want to gets punch in the face
we don't know that's the biggest
question that's the big how's he gonna
do when he's down two rounds and there's
three more to go and you got Brock
Lesnar you know standing across the cage
yeah I do think fighting has holds a
very unique place it's just different
animal like the best athlete isn't
always the ball so wouldn't you say that
your margin for error like it's really
hard to get good at being able to slip
punches see punches measure distance
answer back when you get punched again
they're like good like Tyson says
everybody has a plan to get punched in
the face I don't care who you are when
somebody catches you in the chin or
breaks your nose even though you're
really tough it is different you get
your brain rattled and then you get your
brain rattled again it is a very
different thing absolutely I mean just
to get your reactions to a point where
if they need to be you need to be doing
it for a period of time long break
second nature yes for sure do you find
yourself on any special diet now because
your body's taken so much punishment
they just do it I mean like now I try to
eat I mean last night I trained I got
done about 11:00 and I ate I think I was
little Twix things I think I had like 14
he word word craft services and he has a
doughnut he goes I'm eating this I'm
like all right whatever you guys design
I don't care
I'll eat it and I'll work it off and
he's like he's justified to do the same
thing I just made you I why are you
about last night the comments or
symptoms go around
I'm gonna have half I'm gonna have this
half he's making tomorrow more and I run
all right they're all so I played in the
world football league for Sacramento we
won the world championship you know the
NFL had it it was their kind of farm
league thing right and I played with the
dude named Jon Niese who was on the
first year of MTV the house thing real
world the real world okay he was the
model on it right and he was our punter
and he was so vain that he would have a
dip cup when he'd happened he'd have
like a chocolate bar and he take a bite
of the chocolate and he'd chew it like
four or five times
swish them around and spit it out wow
I'm like you know what I'm never glad I
grew up on a HAMP you know hot dogs at
Coney Island er yeah and hamburgers and
so my deal is this I ain't no fricking
model right I'm a D lineman I'm a
fricking crow Magnum dude but I don't
like being fat and I have you know and I
have an image and and you know and I
don't feel good if I share him fat and
you know essentially I meant and I want
to be at the best of my game so I'm not
vain by any stretch imagination but it's
another competitive thing it's like if
they don't want to be in as best of
shape as I can but yet I've not given up
food you know so I'm gonna have to work
my ass even harder because I ain't
giving up then so do you just eat bass
eat whatever you want buddy just working
off yeah I heard I heard two guys one
was a green beret and the other was
Steve Rinella who's a master hunter and
does Alpine hunting it's really good at
climbing
he's insane Mountains and I've been on
four trips with him cheese where where
Steve likes to suffer Steve will there's
no trail he'll just bleh through and if
there's the hardest peak to climb you're
climbing it with them and it's gonna
suck and you're gonna sit there in the
random fries and and then my buddy
that's nothing sounds like fun oh by the
way by the way it blows yeah but it
blows we realize like Steve you just
want to suffer you want to sleep in
water you want to take a seaplane to a
to a [ __ ] crater lake in Alaska and
sit there and by the way it was it was
gale force winds I was in my template 13
hours oh and by the way all the animals
they were like blah
yes they went low anything I saw
sleeping dear and I'm mama bear who was
keeping her cubs away from the male
bears that were down down below even the
animals were like you guys going you
[ __ ] saw I'm not look at these idiot
six days me and Rogan saw nothing
see that's what Brock would do yeah oh
yeah he could the ice to go outside ice
I talked to him buddy
what are you done I'm ice fishing well
that takes a lot of [ __ ] effort what
are you doing you sitting on the couch
you're in a house you're on a [ __ ]
lake that's frozen you're looking at a
hole people love that [ __ ] and Steve's
like that Rennell is like that so he's a
master hunter and we're sitting there
and Sammy with my green brain friend I
said what do you eat like you've learned
the art of alpine hiking and he I swear
to God he goes kandi I go honey good
makes my body feel energy I have candy
all candy all day then we have dinner I
go but I mean where he goes that [ __ ]
off my buddy Matt who is a great break I
go would you guys heat because you know
I was into this raw food thing and I was
like I had all this and he's just giant
guy like you guys but just a batter he
was out green braids for seven years and
he goes on he goes what I eat mostly
M&Ms I go but I mean do do is hey hey
listen I'm hiking all day I need the
calories [ __ ] yourself give me all the
[ __ ] peanut M&Ms I can get that's all
doll Cerrone Anna Anna Wayne this is
years ago and here's the bag gummy bears
he's gone away and I go what the [ __ ]
what you know Donald sounds like give a
[ __ ] you can't mean gummy bears man
that's why like Dean when I cut away I'm
like that didn't make sense all right
man yeah there is a thing also that I
had read um this doctor was talking
about sometimes apparently when you have
a certain makeup genetic makeup so if
you have a lot of muscle fast twitch
muscle apparently your body utilizes
glycogen in a different way so you
actually break down sugar better than
some other people so some people don't
break down carbs and sugar the way
somebody else does so they do find that
people who are like for example really
fast and super muscular can you utilize
sugar and still not great for you if I
overdo it but the survey did come
out like a super in-depth kind of
research with diet as far as do you know
the the low-carb stuff like you know how
people say no you can have cards so the
same the high fat diets finally like
that's the thing that is I love carbs
yeah and I'll sit there need a loaf of
bread yeah it's just a Goldberg thing
unfortunately goddamn loaf of bread but
I got to work it off I mean hey I like
what you do give an I like what kind of
cardio are you doing though
what's that would you say work it off
you're in there just doing deadlift but
you're training more on die arrogated 40
[ __ ] fruit trees the other day in a
hundred degree weather gotta do it I
mean I'm out shopping trees I'm out hey
I'm an anticipation guy yeah yeah I
don't like sitting on a [ __ ] you know
cardio machine you know staring at a TV
you're looking at a you know an iPad or
something yeah I got a beep you know
going wet and then I'm gonna go for it
yeah whatever I'd rather just jump in
there and go for it man because it's
been if I have to think about it I I see
the misery in what I'm involved in yeah
if not I like what he does this son son
plays video games okay but tell me what
you do with your son I saw one hundred
hundred hundred he does a hundred jump
attacks or no a hundred jump row it
doesn't he can pick okay whatever he
does but a hundred jump rope 100 pushups
in 100 sit-ups for 20 minutes on the I
bet I like it
so I mean there'll be times when he does
of like three times a day 20 minutes 40
minutes a [ __ ] 60 minutes and iPad he
does do three hundred push-ups 300 jump
rope and 300 sit-ups I dig that cuz
they're gonna be on it no matter what
they have to figure out something yeah
yeah for yes I like that
yeah you got a pic figure something out
you can't be that guy that your son's
gonna hate because you don't want them
to touch a video yeah you don't the
weird there's a comment that sugar
doesn't know what the iPad is he's a
know a kid he knows everything when you
do that when you when you bring your
children up in this really restrictive
they're gonna repel eventually yeah it's
just kind of how many preachers
daughters want to suck your dick
immediately
I got myself right out of it I told that
time that girl goes why I love the Lord
I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] you in your
car tonight sure I did that before the
Sun came down and so and I should it's
reduced some current events do some
goddamn but he got Jim Oberg is it
toasty in here now he just beat burns he
go buried since he's sweating all the
time we're doing our thing it's great
let's see all right the first one is
Kevin Hart's been going on social media
kind of putting his friends out there
going you should donate $25,000 and he
picked a bunch of different people and
Master P is saying that that's kind of
messed up to do it's a little messed up
I do it's a little missed yeah I like
text them don't put on social media also
we do have national emergency relief
like we do have FEMA we do have our
government is praise capable of about
the 10 billion fund that the state of
Texas has for disaster yeah there's a
lot of money that state and federal you
know coffers can donate so yeah but I
it's embarrassing to call them out back
a look are you gonna donate and
everyone's turning like do are you going
to tomorrow yeah yeah because and I love
Kevin Hart bloggers must be on this
which I'm surprised I agree with master
beyond anything and he says that most of
the celebrities are donating anyways but
they keep it kind of private yeah that's
out there not everybody wants everybody
to know exactly if they do know in some
way shape or form they're gonna get the
possibly get the wrong impression that
you're doing it just for the publicity
that's a really good board then other
people see you know charity and stuff
we're gonna start reaching out or you
know it's just a bad look you know yeah
you don't need to do that yeah alright
so Joel Olsteen Joel Osteen he's you
know he's like this preacher with this
enormous church he's super famous I
don't trust that guy he's very
charismatic I've listened to him speak
like I need like I know I'm like I want
to be I wanted to be friends and he
smiles his hair is great
he's only writing a creepy when you
walked him in yeah he rides guy from
Game of Thrones the the guy he has like
nice haircut you know I forget his name
he's just another modern-day Oral
Roberts yet but anyways I don't trust
him carry on it's so funny you mention a
game of Thrones guy but I'll talk about
that after this so this guy he
apparently didn't want to open his
church
evacuees in fine yeah because the social
social media backlash so he eventually
he tweeted out like of course it just
wasn't ready yet he even said that the
church was flooded
it wasn't yeah and he was like it we
were waiting till it's like what's wrong
I think he doesn't want to mess up his
beautiful Church exam I'm being honest
yeah that's all based upon donations
that he's pilfered from people yes like
rich I don't trust him in he's a lot I'm
worried about them he's um you guys are
wrong he's a beautiful man he's so much
a megachurch man he is
I remember watching him as a young man I
was like this dude is so charismatic
that's smile and the way he would talk
and somehow he just make you feel like
the world
y'all need was the world was just okay
when you were talking to him and he said
in that and I want you to make up was
that on television out here because
there's a Midwest and it was all over
what we were watchin every he was all
over all over the rug though and that
hair and that space and for $14.99 if
you just put in my paypal can't exactly
just will love you more you just believe
him he spoke in a very very you know
what I saw this yes yes yeah he's been
going around Derrick Lewis Derrick the
black piece he's been going around
Houston with his giant truck and saving
people's lives pulling kids out a huge
monster truck right look at that's
bitchin man I love him that's great news
that's his enormous truck and that's all
the people he's saving that's awesome
Liam just doing work there's the photo I
was talk I wish this one I would you
know I think this is just a different
random photo but yeah he's doing some
good work out there good great it's
awesome shout to Derrick Lewis I like
that guy big shout out um ed skrein so
this is the guy from Game of Thrones
he played the REO what happened so okay
he was casting a Hellboy reboot while of
Hellboy but at the comic I guess the guy
that he was cast as was supposed to be
Asian or half asian
okay so Ed's crying ed skrein found out
that and he left the role
yeah so if I know Bobby Lee has
Bobby was talking about stuff like this
here right like a white actress taking
over Asian roles yeah but also it's
called racism off let him be if he's the
best actor for the role let him play the
Asian guy in the [ __ ] cartoon but he
did it voluntarily uh yeah he did it
voluntarily but excuse me but he got a
lot of pressure from far left-wing
groups these [ __ ] these these people
who are just identity politics at its
best
wait so what if what if like Martin
Luther King but that's a real person
what if that was cast as like Oh
everything about the guy for ESPN oh
yeah Robert Lee he's in Charlotte Ville
calling the game and he is playing -
yeah that's a little insensitive you
[ __ ] you that is weird
that's what it's always the gate goes
back to use now what you think it's how
you think and they're thinking the same
way the far right the far left think the
same way they think the same way I'm
sorry he said recent years
Alki over Scarlett Johansson playing a
Japanese character Japanese I'd be like
what the [ __ ] I get it if you're if
you're Asian and you're trying to get
jobs in Hollywood we all deal with it
but I also get the market like you like
American fans that is what it is the
United States if it's this random Asian
played this role with what Scarlett
Johansson right Scarlett Johansson's get
my money and she's probably really good
she goes Studios know that he's also
crazy talented yes so so you know what
that's exactly right
it's called a business if Scarlett
Johansson puts more butts and seats then
pull it then then random Asian actor who
might be very talented it well I've been
living that reality and never whining
about it since I've been in this
business it's just the way it goes and
it should go that way by the way if
you're casting average white male
challenger guys if you want to average
at every average they got 15 year old if
you want hands
[ __ ] that Here I am guys who looks now
you're gonna cast Bobby Lee as Captain
America [ __ ] you yeah I can't have that
yeah I can't happen
to turn draw picket that [ __ ] right away
but when there is your cell but I was
down with that I thought that was cool
that's what it's supposed to use James
Bond he's going to be white right yeah
busy drew say something for me even me
he's very James Bond tall handsome as
[ __ ] and dark with glorg
nice conversation we are we are like the
emoji now I can't remember it I don't
want to open up a big can of worms but
black in like yeah sometimes I don't
know how to switch them I just do that
one yeah just pick whichever ones first
I mean all at the end of the day look at
okay and they say everything happens for
a reason
no look at the country coming together
right now in Texas you can't pick a
better place for something horrible to
happen and have people come together
than Texas yeah you know I mean that
state how self-sufficient they are and
how they're helping the bible's right
now I mean it's absolutely unbelievable
why black green Jewish Muslim whatever
the [ __ ] it is all that secondary oh
that's [ __ ] that's right all right
some ten-year-old boy saved his
brother's life after he was drowning in
a pool through watching what the rock
did in a movie called San Andreas nice
and that's his Oh cutie pie he actually
did compressions on his chest pulled on
the water and exactly what Wow when you
have children there's nothing oh my God
thank God that little boy's okay he on
his fine yeah so sweetheart he is
awesome and the rock centers like he was
shot out yeah rocketing great but
looking good
how old is the rock 47 48 to 4 I'm gonna
guess 43 might be even older it's all
and then rock three blasts ah I got to
shake the hand of a real-life
ten-year-old hero Jake I'm gonna fly you
and your favorite to Vancouver so I can
beat you
Wow
oh god damn it damn the rocket oh god
he's okay
yeah good job gonna do everything he can
those lifetime for any kid man it's just
anybody less fortunate is it funny we
only have one honey if only one that's
all I can spit out you did it it's funny
when you have kids man you just love
ball kids what changes everything
yeah it does yeah what else you got how
about this there's a fan at the fight
that Mayweather McGregor fight who snuck
down all the way to the $25,000 seat
good for him is right and check out how
many pictures you took with all these
different celebrities this is an Irish
dude there it is there so it's the
bald-headed guy he's with P Diddy Dana
White
Demi Lovato Aamir Khan Thor didn't
reform easily everyone yeah he's been
drinking hold his breath right far cry
from the Spartan everybody celebrities
like why but okay one dollar is what
happens if they find out afterwards do
they get what's crazy is I don't know
how I did that because the security
around that had this new thing where we
at our our backstage passes and like my
media pass our vouchers so I had to go
around your neck it had my picture on it
it was like this laminate like hologram
thing and you have to scan through every
little section at the scan it and it
would bring up he's a ballsy little guy
he found his way he's going to
celebrities go on let me take a picture
yeah that's crazy man is that hardcore
jail though or not no no baby just let
that go
no okay what can you call the American
Way brother yeah what's neat down there
and take an opportunity hilarious
Oh wonderful good late is this Liam
whatever his name is get laid what's
that Chris Hemsworth crimson tortha he's
a handsome kid big boy - is he yeah at
all uh calling me Wi-Fi installing me
what yeah Jesus can box Viking what a
sketch in about all right I'm not sure
where this is at but I saw it scored us
Florida okay
rectum this guy got pulled over he had
wallet ton of cash on that loose booty
although I took him to the station and
the officer saw like 20 dollar bills
coming out of his butt so he all the
money got to keep it in a cylinder guys
and you got a you got a dipper cylinder
they found space a thousand dollars
hidden it's gonna water the cylinder
butter the cylinder and keep it in a
cylinder in a process cops called
necessary but undesirable holy Sh oh
look what he's charged with though
smuggling contraband into a detention
facility trafficking meta meth
trafficking heroin possession of cocaine
with in there was a seven month old kid
will in his but I think you guys covered
this dirty but JJ Watt he tried to raise
$200,000 and now it's up to over six
million I think it's almost at 10
million he's house how is he cooking
no he just black all Instagram his own
not doing [ __ ] : he's out he's on
that's calling he's not so he's on
Twitter and challenged people said I'm
certainly go fund me you know this thing
must come to a tree built like to me
just puts the link obviously like you
put the tickets I'm sure cell sorry
probably tickets and then you raise
money for do you wear too fast and
attack my shows in Philly
yo JJ its Brian uh oh by the way here's
ten bucks he's killing it yeah he's
raised a ton of money man that's also a
killer huh this dude was walking down
New York and there's a sinkhole
Brooklyn alright it looks walking at a
cross street and he and his leg got
stuck in there I think he actually
messed up his back - oh yeah no [ __ ] he
missed them back fall through the road
I've thought about that yeah I fell
about that - yeah I try to not stand
what so what's the worst Andrew you've
had Goldberg from racing like Walt was
while you're wrestling
oh you can pull that one up yeah
yo Ronnie bashes limousine I got a
hundred ninety nine stitches of my right
arm for taking a limousine out cuz I was
pissed off and that was real it was real
stupid and when you smash that it's real
here right here
now what's your thought process as
you're doing this for god sakes right
here oh that must have hurt right here
was it embarrassing you didn't crack on
you just broke all that [ __ ] and you
realize it too because you looked at
your hair does that realize that's real
[ __ ] glass hurt oh yeah no it's
[ __ ] sugar Brian but you're but
you're breaking oh look at the blood on
the car what the hell were you thinking
I was I was pissed off but why are you
so mad there's a business car with a
kill for real and I just would use
everything at the time to make the
character more intense uh
and as opposed to grabbing a
sledgehammer to beat the car up I chose
not to I mean I had Sammy I don't never
try to break a window but I'm impressed
that you were able to crush that
windshield that easily is that that's
not easy right no no you don't I mean
I've broken a car win but but it's just
a bad idea I was doing but it was the
highest-rated whole evening segment on
cable television at the time 190
stitches do you get boat do they give
you bonuses for that like you get money
for that how's that worked you like in
the UFC I do something cool I get a
bonus do you get bonus about using nails
like Nick x100 no is WCW that was just
me trying to take the character to a
different level and you went too far a
little yet you have Jared Leto you just
got a little too into the character yeah
that'll do it okay yeah I was just a
little and how many stitches 190
something
it was it sucked it came within like a
centimeter or losing they using my arm
what really you have back neck issues
necks always [ __ ] up yeah pretty bad
shape like that really now you get white
has a four-way why he's got a four-way
what why you work out a lot died he
stays keep supple well I work a lot of
it is just to stay to make everything
flow you don't have died no but I mean
it's just if I would stop training with
my shoulders right I don't be able to
lift my [ __ ] arms and yeah as my you
know rotator needs a muscle the
stratifying on that he needs the muscle
so you move everything right bingo Paris
Jackson birthday wishes to the love of
my life the one person who showed me
what passion truly was the one who came
e solid morals lived by and out a dream
oh we got a bunch of emails about Pierce
Jackson and logic she's half black and
logic that white rapper I thought was
white he's half black he were making fun
of us oh she had a bowl that black what
they say black ah I don't believe them I
love my opinion we are the one our souls
will never change that way thank you the
magic for why are you bringing this up
just because it's his birthday yesterday
today he's been a 69 I think you've been
60 or 50 mm-hmm talk to lose your daddy
man yeah that'd be a bummer go over your
dad graduated from Harvard is that right
Johns Hopkins Harvard do you know about
B yes to have is a doctor he was just
OBGYN yeah yeah anyways yeah Mike
Jackson died many years ago Jim what's
his birthday and I told you sold 170
someone uh this t-shirt come here wear
their shirts all the time they're like
hey we want to sing this Michael Jackson
shirt I meant never gonna wear it like
really went a tough time we're not
would you wear Michael Jackson shirt
suppose you have kids like no it's not
that I don't like Michael Jack let's
just don't like I'm not I mean what he
stands for I don't really I can't mess
with it I can't
touch that period well yes I can't yes
there's a number of reasons why right
here they're like what it was up his my
Jack's is that in the 80s I'm like I
don't care he was our first he was our
first he was our first public
transgender transracial man was a
terrible joke definitely wasn't but not
at my age he died in our age did well he
but he died my gender this man he died
of that because the doctor is leaving
stuff but like like Bill Cosby when the
greatest communes all time I'm not
willing to build Cosby sure there's no
you things are the child monster yeah
but he there was never really an was he
ever convicted it was that rumors was
that all [ __ ] or is there enough
smoke there's fire you're saying you're
gonna air I said I feel like his his
public persona was so tainted by that I
have again I can't wear a Michael
Jackson shirt I never I never thought of
that
I honestly the first thing I thought of
huh I'm like I can't III that's so funny
I didn't see I actually I really never
forget and I could somehow forgot about
that I don't know why we're all the
little boys yeah there's all those
people that came out there was my skin
and Vanity Fair that was a very
well-written article and researched
article about the first accusation by
that lawyer and it was it was you know
when you read that article and you look
at all the sides man oh man these guys
are scumbags they were trying to [ __ ]
him and here's what his brother said it
made a lot of sense said so they settled
out of court
okay your son's been molested by men and
you were willing to take money to settle
that you didn't take a trauma molester
to court and and follow through if you
molest my child what's the first thing I
want I want you off the street so you
don't molest another child
forget the revenge and all that we all
have I want that guy I don't if you
molest children I don't care what the
situation is I don't you can't be a
Disraeli with a little bit of with that
because if let's say he settled for who
knows
20 million dollars it's Michael Jackson
so let's say you go to court are you
really gonna be on a battle you think
Michael Jackson's spend the rest of his
life in prison
I really making that much of a
difference or I get 20 million I can set
my kids up there kids are you gonna have
the money to
fund your your court team yeah you know
your lawyer but good luck out out
battling Michael James well I you know
and that every child has been if there's
enough evidence that I know I get it my
issue is it what just wasn't that one
and then also as a grown man to have
kids stay the night at his house yeah
and have a whole compound called the
Neverland Ranch the magico burgers yeah
I got a place down in San Diego man I
got kids there all the time
I caught the neverland golden Ram never
leave my house never later out and then
I constantly throw parties have little
kids I guess the [ __ ] wrong I use up
kids over yeah that's all good do you no
no my gosh that's why he probably didn't
believe that he'd molested his kid he
just took the money if he especially
he's letting this kid go there that's
what I like that well that article I'm
sure they're subunit just job was very
damning for the accuser side it because
they're they're all it's a great article
I'm just sayin out but their hold on
that's a grown man that one to go from
black to white and do all that stuff to
his face and then buys a place called
the neverland ranch and that's kid
parties 24/7 hangs out with my kids not
coming over hangs out with kids all the
time that's okay
can't watch the street you can't wear
your sleepovers non-stop though like
that just think kids stay over all the
time
I can't Reaper you told me hey by we're
doing this again Oh brah get these 10
year olds coming over we're just gonna
crash I don't I love the way you see
your kid I can hang out are they your to
here though maybe three minutes and then
I'm like alright go play yeah but he's
having sleepovers
I just think it's normal I play your
brother on the gold yeah yeah yeah I
don't know I [ __ ] totally forgot
about that
I told one wise I can't wear your
goddamn yeah well they did invite well
he was not convicted of anything right I
mean there was souls to shame
there's a lot of smoke right I wouldn't
touch it if more than 12 kids like he
touched my dick and tried to give me
coca-cola does that sir you're laughing
at MA station please
I'm just saying yeah we're the smoke
this fire I'm living in him yeah no
you're right yeah yeah I would have to
say there's some controversy around yeah
well you sure can't wear Cosby shirt
yeah I don't have any friends who I hang
out with 1000 men no wait what wants to
a party for the grown-ups you have more
money than God
yeah and why is this a shitty Disneyland
around here just a the first thing they
tell you when you have children there's
no such thing as a male babysitter you
do not get [ __ ] my kid can only watch
like two people on the story besides me
enjoy the [ __ ] are we what the hell's
going on
I just [ __ ] completely forgot about
that part of Michael Jackson yeah good
for Michael Jackson good yeah job Mike
James PR are those boots those rocks
mm-hmm I like those boots you like those
boots I do like this like dozing you
don't like mine well your goals are
craftsmanship Bert's boots aren't our no
no there are my why it sells my Saint
Lawrence that look kind of like that no
without the croc no I like rum the
Italian yes they're telling dad that's
that that's it that's what's really
weird sometimes Jimmy you're at your
Oklahoma guy I am I am is what it is
never ride a bull no mm-hmm III don't
like [ __ ] with things that could kill
me yeah you like having the draw
you think yeah yeah that's to Annette to
a fault
yeah unfortunately I worked out though
brother I think it has appreciate you
coming down there that's a long-ass
drive yeah you're the best I wish you
the best brother check him out on the
carpet wanted to meet you for a long
John oh man getting the hang with him on
the show is a great deal man we're gonna
do more of it lifted that would be
awesome man yeah I'd love the
opportunity yeah he's been great man
wait so check us out we're gonna we're
playing brothers but you guys come down
to Diego man when you when you do it go
down there just come hang for sure man
let's definitely do have to shoot some
guns you want guns don't you bill
depends on where your mouth
beep tell me where you'd be at man
Madison Wisconsin
first I'll be in Kabul down at Del Mar
I'm doing that I'm doing that festival
like I said you got a hangover yep come
to a show and then I got my run the kids
Madison 21 22 23 of September comedy on
state and then I got helium in Philly
September 28 29 30 get your take as a
teef at kake.com and I'm in San
Francisco September 14th Cobbs comedy
club in the 22nd Long Beach Laugh
Factory get tickets right now t fact
AECOM tomorrow Thursday 5:00 p.m.
Pacific skeptical hippo and stake and
suck T's drop on T fat K calm as well
this is the fire kid with Goldberg we're
out